aujourd'hui nous allons en apprendre un
peu plus sur le dispositif r+cie un
nouveau dispositif du département qui
réunit le R+ et le contrat initiative
emploi en associant leurs avantages
respectifs allons voir ça
[Musique]
le R+C c'est l'association de deux
dispositifs le R+ et le CIE sous forme
de contrats d'engagement entre les
bénéficiaires et le département le but
du contrat est l'insertion durable du
bénéficiaire du RSA dans l'emploi à
travers un accompagnement renforcé en
faveur de l'entreprise et du salarié en
insertion combinant la mobilisation de
la location d'insertion et de retour à
l'emploi R+ et du contrat initiative
emploi Cie bonjour Lily bonjour Elsa
alors Elsa vous avez bénéficié du
dispositif R+ comment cela vous a-t-il
aidé ça m'a aidé financièrement être
plus sereine sur neuf mois car en
reprenant une activité salariée je
perdais toutes mes aides et là ça
contribue une partie à ne pas perdre mes
aides jusqu'à ce que je sois plus stable
votre employeur Lily a bénéficié d'un
autre dispositif le CIE racontez-nous
comment cela vous a aidé alors moi
pareil en sortie de pandémie on est une
jeune entreprise ça faisait clairement
qu'on était ouvert mais on devait
recruter mais vu les conditions assez
risqué donc j'ai pareil j'ai contacté le
Pôle emploi qui donc nous a présenté
Elsa et à ce moment-là ils nous ont
proposé donc le contrat Cie qui nous
permettait d'avoir l'aide de 30% de
prise en charge de son salaire ça nous
permettait d'un donc de prendre moins de
risques au niveau financier de pouvoir
aussi la former en poste et tout ça sur
9 mois
merci Elsa merci Lily merci
les évaluations ont montré que c'est
avec les entreprises que le déploiement
du R+ doit être amplifié c'est l'enjeu
du r+cie les avantages du R+ et ce du
dispositif contrat initiative emploi
bonjour monsieur maillot bonjour
Alexandre alors le dispositif R+ a été
mis en place en 2020 et a été une
réussite avec 86% de bénéficiaires
satisfaits le département a souhaité le
faire évoluer en le couplant au CIO
dites-nous-en un peu plus il y a plus
d'un bénéficiaire sur deux du R+ qui
lorsqu'il est recruté dans une
entreprise va voir son emploi pérennisé
et donc on a souhaité prolonger cette
dynamique dans une association plus
forte entre les dispositifs
d'accompagnement des entreprises et le
dispositif r+, c'est le r+cie et en quoi
consiste cet accompagnement et bien
c'est à la fois des aides financières
accordées par le Département aussi bien
à l'entreprise qu'au bénéficiaire du RSA
et puis c'est l'accompagnement aussi que
va apporter le conseiller d'insertion du
département l'ensemble du dispositif est
formalisé dans un contrat tripartite en
fait chacun s'engage le bénéficiaire du
r+, s'engage à mettre en œuvre toutes
les actions nécessaires à son insertion
à son dans l'emploi l'entreprise
s'engage à faciliter cette intégration
dans l'emploi et le département s'engage
à accompagner cet effort d'insertion
aussi bien celui qui est fourni par le
bénéficiaire du RSA que celui qui est
fourni par l'entreprise très bien merci
Monsieur maillot merci Alexandre
[Musique]
quand sur le dispositif R + Cie
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affichent sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est fini si vous souhaitez revoir cet
épisode ainsi que les précédents
rendez-vous sur nos sites et nos réseaux
sociaux à bientôt
la semaine prochaine le rencontre auront
Marielle qui a pu bénéficier du
dispositifs chaque santé une aide
financée du département qui a été mise
en place pour permettre aux personnes
âgées aux revenus modestes de payer le
reste à charge mensuel que leur un
comble auprès d'une mutuelle affilié
[Musique]